[Música]
ahora vamos ahora de salud en directo
france24 y más romero sala ya
está lista en el estudio para hablar de
los olores más porque un estudio muestra
de cómo es importante los dolores
corporales para nosotros los humanos de
qué estamos hablando buenos días raúl
efectivamente salió la noticia hace unos
días y ha tenido mucha repercusión no es
un estudio del instituto de ciencias
weizmann de israel
publicado en la revista science advanced
es sus principales conclusiones son que
los humanos igual que otros mamíferos
usamos estos dolores para construir
relaciones de amistad personales en este
caso como hicieron buscaron parejas de
amistades de personas del mismo género
que definieron su amistad como una
amistad clic es decir que desde el
inicio hubiera una relación de confianza
que fuera un instantáneo casi como un
flechazo pero en las amistades
analizaron esos dolores corporales y
vieron que eran más similares que la
similitud similar y tú media digamos
entre personas que tenían más relación
sus dolores que cuando cogían personas a
las luego para corroborar también esta
teoría porque recordemos es un estudio
pequeño fueron unas 20 parejas en total
cogieron a personas desconocidas entre
ellas y las pusieron a hacer un
ejercicio de espejo que es cuando hacen
mímica dos personas sin poder hablar
para que no hubiera comunicación verbal
y luego vieron que personas también
decían haber sentido una conexión
instantánea con esta otra persona que
habían tenido enfrente que vimos en esos
resultados pues que según este grado de
empatía o grado de conexión reportada
por las dos partes de la pareja también
había unos dolores más similares de
naranja vemos a lo que pasó entre los
hombres en morado lo que pasó entre las
mujeres los recuadros también que están
marcados son las personas que dijeron
sentir ese click y cuanto más intensos
del color es que más se parecían sus
dolores igualmente vemos que a pesar de
que hay esta correlación
significativamente en la estadística
pues hay algunas excepciones hay otros
factores que pueden influir en el mismo
gráfico vemos algunos recuadros marcados
que son de un color más pálido entonces
pues también tenemos que 100 como
siempre todos estos resultados con
cierta prudencia y laron siempre siento
más entonces cómo se generan nuestros
olores bueno el olor sobre todo viene
desde la piel desde la piel que recubre
todo nuestro cuerpo de las glándulas
sudoríparas que hay repartidas por todo
nuestro cuerpo y también es muy
importante decir que el olor de una
persona puede estar determinado por
hasta más de 6000 moléculas es decir que
son realmente complejas de estas
químicas que suceden además puede
cambiar es decir las personas podemos
oler distinto a raíz del estrés por
ejemplo si agregamos un ácido láctico
que esto se puede notar en el olor igual
pasa con el miedo hay una feromona que
se genera con el miedo o con la
adrenalina que se puede llegar a sentir
en el olor y pues todo esto entonces nos
hace pensar que si en realidad hay
muchos animales sobre todo los mamíferos
que usan el olor para construir sus
vínculos con otros animales mamíferos
porque pues los humanos no somos tan
diferentes y de hecho este era una de
las conclusiones que remarcaban en el
estudio
el olfato es una información sensorial
dominante subyacente en las
interacciones sociales esto se reconoce
ampliamente en otros mamíferos
terrestres pero normalmente se rechaza
en los humanos en los humanos el rol del
feto ha sido denigrado en parte por
varios tabúes sociales culminando en la
idea de que el olfato no es importante
para la socialización humana en este
estudio detectamos que los humanos usan
información olfativa para guiar sus
preferencias en las interacciones no
románticas entre personas del mismo sexo
pasamos a hablar de otro tema mari cómo
nos afecta el consumo de alcohol y las
nuevas recomendaciones de expertos
teniendo en cuenta que evidentemente no
está de ninguna manera recomendado tomar
alcohol exacto empezando por ahí no hay
un consumo cero que sea responsable o
sea no hay un consumo moderado que sea
responsable lo recomendable siempre es
el consumo cero de alcohol yo sé que a
veces desearíamos escuchar otras cosas
pero en estas son las recomendaciones
que salieron la semana pasada el
congreso internacional del hígado que se
celebró en londres y el mensaje clave
que han intentado transmitir estos
grupos de expertos es que al menos
deberíamos pasar tres días de la semana
seguidos
en consumir alcohol porque para dejar
regenerar y recuperarse al hígado que
ahora veremos que es el órgano que
filtra la mayor parte de esta sustancia
de nuevo eso asumir que no hay ningún
tipo de consumo de alcohol que sea
saludable lo hemos hablado en otros
espacios que pueden recuperar en la
página web de france 24 también es el
mito de que una copa de vino al día es
saludable no lo es también pidieron
regulaciones desde las políticas
públicas por ejemplo igual que sucede
con el tabaco aumentar el precio
disminuir la publicidad que recibe no
recordemos el alcohol es una sustancia
que se ha demostrado que es cancerígena
además también es una sustancia adictiva
y sobre todo recarga el hígado ahora
vamos a hablar de este órgano provoca
enfermedades como la inflamación
hepática como la cirrosis que
básicamente es como si todo el hígado se
convirtiera en una especie de cicatriz y
pudo dejar de funcionar como una filtro
y por último el 90% de las enfermedades
hepáticas son prevenibles ese es el
mensaje también más importante
y le pregunto qué pasa entonces en
nuestro cuerpo cuando tomamos alcohol
sobre todo en nuestro hígado que estamos
hablando de eso si vamos a repasar lo
para entender a qué lo sometemos cuando
tomamos el alcohol básicamente se
ingiere igual que la comida otros
líquidos llega al estómago allí es donde
se absorbe es decir pasa a la sangre
aproximadamente entre el 10 y el 20 por
ciento de este alcohol después es cuando
llega al intestino según por ejemplo
además si hemos comido mucho o poco es
que nos sentimos más alcoholizados o no
precisamente porque la rapidez en la que
se queda en el estómago pasa al
intestino pero bueno el 80 90% del
alcohol se absorbe en este intestino
llega al riego sanguíneo ahí es cuando
notamos nosotros los efectos del alcohol
y en la sangre es donde llega al hígado
que es donde se va a filtrar ahí hay
unas enzimas que son un tipo de
proteínas que hacen este proceso de
oxidación del alcohol y es donde pues se
depura pero se crean estas sustancias
que son tan tóxicas para nosotros
entonces dejar descansar el hígado
importante para para nuestra salud así
es más muchísimas gracias como siempre
por toda la información mañana por
supuesto más salud pasamos a saludar a
nuestra segunda mitad al día